Hello Freak bitches.
One of the main things,
I think that my advice would be,
it's a lot easier to focus on what you
should eat then on what you shouldn't.
And I think that an more inclusionary
diet is,
is key.
So focusing on what your body needs,
you know,
not only for short term but what it
needs for long term focus on that more
than yeah,
because,
because it's just,
first of all,
if you focus on what you're limiting
from your diet,
then you're not going to be getting all
the good stuff that you need.
That's part of the talking a lot about
loss.
You're also thinking,
it's just like,
it's so there's too many little,
it's easy to become caught up in a lot
of minutia.
Um,
and I know this because I've been there.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
getting caught up in all this little
minutia,
you know,
it can take you forever to try to figure
out what's going on.
And then in the meantime you're getting
distracted from the important thing is
not as what you need.
You know,
your body,
your body is very resilient.
And if you feed it what it needs,
you can fight off stuff.
You're going to,
you're going to age better.
You know,
all these little chemical reactions and
enzymatic reactions going on in all your
cells,
in your liver and your kidney and your
brain.
All these things are going to keep
happening because you're feeding it.
And when you have a little bit of toxic
stuff,
guess what?
All of these pathways are ready because
they're so,
they're getting nourished,
are getting what they need that they
activate in the,
your body has protective mechanisms to
make sure it doesn't get cancered.
You know,
I explained that when you make reactive
oxygen species,
you can repair it or you can do the cell
will die.
But all those,
all those repair a stress response
mechanisms,
they require that,
you know,
you're,
you're giving yourselves what they need
to do that.
So if you're so focused on what not to
eat,
that you're not getting enough of what
you need,
then your body is,
you know,
capacity to do that isn't going to be as
optimal.
So I really like,
I really think it's easier,
especially for people that don't have a
scientific background that don't have
time.
I mean because it takes a lot of time to
sit there and read through all the
scientific ses and figuring out what's
going on,
all the complex interactions,
you know,
I barely have time to do that and it's
like I do this every day.
Like I do research every day and on top
of that,
in my spare time I do and it's still
overwhelming and I still can only get so
much done.
Didn't you have like plans on being some
sort of a marine biologist or something?
At some point?
I tell people that story because this is
funny.
On twitter I found this rock,
my daughter found this rock on the beach
in Santa Barbara and had all these holes
in it and we're trying to figure out
what the fuck it was was an asteroid or
something.
I put on twitter,
I go,
what's this rock Joe fucking Perry is
the first guy to answer me on twitter
and tells me it's a see stone.
Like these animals had like burrowed
into this stone and created a little
homes really well
told me.
Well anyway,
listen,
I love the ocean and it captured me from
the very beginning.
I mean,
I love,
I love
Jacques Cousteau and watching those,
those specials and I got to see,
seems speak a couple of times in Boston
and I just was,
uh,
that's what I wanted to be.
I want it to be.
I W I went to woods hole and you know,
visited there and,
and uh,
uh,
and I,
and I thought that's what I wanted to do
was be a marine biologist and uh,
you know,
and the whole learning disability thing,
um,
which they didn't know what to call it
back then except the discipline thing,
you know what I mean?
I wasn't studying hard enough.
Well,
I wanted to,
wanted to get good grades.
They studied as hard as I could.
I mean,
it looked at the page,
read it,
nothing's stuck.
And this lexicon couldn't get grades.
Now it's like a Adhd,
I guess they call it down.
And,
uh,
and that's where,
they have different ways to teach kids
now and it doesn't involve,
you know,
like taking some pills.
I mean there's just different ways of
teaching that,
that work and they just didn't have it
back then.
What would you say to one though?
Like say if someone came along like some
15 year old kid says,
Hey,
I'm a huge UFC fan.
I want to fight in MMA.
Uh,
how should I get started?
I would have him pick one discipline to
start.
If you're 15 years old,
go wrestle.
If he,
if you are more drawn to boxing or
kickboxing and then go do that along the
way.
Play and experiment a little bit.
But athlete development is changing now.
There's this,
this trend for when kids are as young as
five,
six years old that there's these an
intensive training program.
She had larger cities where there's good
resource,
good coaching and good facilities.
They take these kids from an early age,
maybe they train them football or
basketball or hockey,
something like this with the intent of
development professional athletes.
This approaches almost producing zero
professional athletes.
The ones who are successful are the ones
who played three or four sports growing
up and then they get to a certain age
and then they start narrowing in and
kind of defining the best way to be.
What are they going to do?
The Australians did it before the
Olympics in 2000 they started to take it
a whole bunch of metrics on their
athletes finding,
okay,
you're not good enough to win a metal
here.
Have you thought about this,
try this.
And as a result,
the Ozzies,
they've won national governing body for
um,
for their Olympic sports development as
their assault.
They did 10 times per capita.
The man of metals at the u s did in
2012,
um,
in,
in the UK they did the same thing.
They took it a little bit further as
example of one woman who was good,
I think she was some type of distance
runner or something.
They'd all sorts of measurements like
the,
the wrist to elbow measurement.
And this is more technical than than I
know,
but they found,
she had the certain measurement in here
and said,
okay,
you're not going to win a medal in this.
Have you ever considered rowing?
She goes,
I've never done road.
Three years later,
she was an Olympic champion.
Watts.
Yeah.
You could be an Olympic rowing champion
in three years,
but think about if you are already a
well trained athlete for something else,
it involved that type of cardiovascular
stuff.
I have this specific biomechanics that
fits.
So if you know those biomechanics,
sorry,
you know what to look for in an athlete,
you can steer them in this direction.
The UK did great with metal count.
That's amazing.